[Music]
all right creatures
of the internet i'm dave rubin this is
the reuben report and we are
live for another friday panel show
and this is a good one you guys know i
don't overreach when i say that
this is a good one joining me today are
christian
thinker and author of the new book fish
out of water eric mataxis
rabbi of sinai temple in los angeles
author and columnist
rabbi david walpe an author and
assistant professor
at portland state university and atheist
peter burgosian guys welcome to the
reuben report
thank you great to be here thanks dave i
uh i was really looking forward to this
when we decided to do this a couple
weeks ago because it seems to me that
sort of everyone is in some state of
craziness i include myself in that we're
seeing sort of
the truths that we all could agree on
are sort of disintegrating
right in front of us and i thought you
three from a different from a christian
a jewish and an atheist perspective
would be a nice little way to take us
into the weekend
but it hit me right before we started
that uh
rabbi you and i are in crazy los angeles
pete is in completely bananas portland
and eric
you're in psychotic new york city so
what what are we doing wrong with our
lives
what are we doing wrong with our lives
eric you go first what happened here
uh well since i'm a christian i can
think of myself as a missionary
uh new york needs the truth and uh
god planted me here listen i was born in
new york
and we never got very far my folks are
in connecticut my wife's folks
are in jersey so we're equidistant and
up until about a year ago it made a lot
of sense to live in new york but
right now we're beginning to wonder yeah
i bet
my my sister was the last reuben clan
to uh to be there and she fled pete
you're in portland which is probably the
craziest of all of them what in the
world are you doing
yeah i'm plotting and it's either i'm
going to escape and move or run
and i'm totally serious about this or
run for mayor next time
the d.a mike schmidt doesn't process
prosecute people so they just it's a
revolving carcel
the mayor is an absolute disgrace and i
don't know
it's hard to believe at this point that
what's happening is mere incompetence
we've seen the complete there's no plan
to bring the business back
he's preoccupied with pronouns i mean
it's almost like you've fallen into
a different a different universe but i
think escape either escape or office are
the only two choices i don't think it
can be fixed with the current
infrastructure what a world you might
run for mayor of portland and i've told
people that if newsom gets recalled
which i do think will happen i will at
least consider running for governor and
my and truly
my platform would be everything newsom
said i'll do the reverse that's the
whole platform
that's it that's it uh you're my
platform
sorry my platform is going to be even
simpler if you
riot independent of the reasons you riot
you will be arrested
it's literally my i'm running on just
that
you got my vote and i don't even live
there right rabbi you're here
you're here in l.a so i'm here in los
angeles yeah we're still in semi
lockdown
and uh well let's start there what's
that been like for you as someone that
heads a congregation to be
in this state of not knowing when people
can get together
it's actually more than anything else
it's been very painful
because funerals hospital visits
which are the most important if not the
flashiest
things um that rabbis ministers priests
do we can't do that
um and so that's been painful uh and and
i do
you know i think los angeles suffers as
you know
as a as a fellow um somewhat angelino
uh it has this spiritual malady to start
with so
i my own diagnosis it's the thing that's
really wrong with los angeles
is we don't have autumn the problem is
you don't see the beauty of things aging
so in los angeles you're supposed to
have spring spring spring and then die
yeah and the idea that things actually
get older and therefore maturity is
something to be
you know admired and even coveted that
doesn't exist so much here but
but maybe maybe the pandemic will be
something of a reset
for people i'm not sure but but hope
springs eternal
yeah that's really interesting to me
because you know i moved here
seven or eight years ago i lived in new
york my whole life where we had the four
seasons i i moved here one of the
reasons that i am still here
is because of that perpetual spring but
i guess yeah
maybe you do lose something so i thought
i thought an interesting place to start
guys would be uh within your
view of the world during this crazy time
have you had to challenge any of the
beliefs that you had
beforehand uh eric i'll start with you
has this caused me to challenge any of
the beliefs i've had
um on the contrary i think it has
made me more explicit uh
about what i believe i'm i'm less i mean
listen
things have become clearer and clearer
and clearer the horror
you know that was there under the
surface has now
uh come out i mean i'll give you a
strange example of the looniness that
we're living in
um some of you know mike lindell right
he has been on this whole election fraud
thing
and finally put together a documentary
of what he sees as the evidence right
now it doesn't matter what you think of
it
uh i i really uh
i think it's important for us to have
transparency in the election and when
people are trying to do that i honor
that
so i posted this documentary uh
i sent it out to my email list and said
what do you think of this here you go
right today because i did that
google shut down
my email i can't email anyone because i
had the temerity
to share a documentary in which
mild-mannered people
share what they think is evidence of
something bad in america and i thought
can you imagine that they would be so
heavy-handed
it's the heavy-handedness that tells you
something's wrong
right are you saying you literally can't
get into your own gmail account right
now because of that
that's correct i did they did they and
do you know anything
yeah oh i know i know i don't know it's
the reason it's never happened before
but we sent out an email blast to my
list which is not a monumental list but
i kind of thought this is important mike
lindell has put a lot of work and a lot
of his own money into this
people should look at this so i sent it
out and within a couple of hours
my assistant told me our we can't send
out emails from the ericmataxis.com
account which is gmail and i thought
you're kidding and then suddenly runs oh
okay they have decided
to shut us down because we shared a
documentary now
that's what has happened to me in this
last year in other words every week that
goes by
the absurdity ratchets up and you think
even if i weren't
convinced that something fishy was going
on i would be convinced
by the way people are behaving when you
shut somebody down
i mean i was knocked off youtube i was
knocked off twitter but i'm i'm thinking
for sharing something like this for
gmail
to shut down our account it makes you
more vocal and i've written about this
in some biographies luther uh i was
saying when he was
rebelling against the catholic church it
was because they treated him so poorly
that he became increasingly outspoken if
they had played nice with him
he he never wanted a a revolution or a
reformation
and i i feel like that's what happens
when you treat people poorly it happened
listen it happened to the colonists in
the 13 colonies you know
king george could have played it
differently but by trying to
crush them he made them angrier and
angrier
so i have become much more
open about my views than i was a year or
so ago just because i've been
truly disgusted to see this kind of
fundamentally anti-american thing
happening in the greatest country in the
world it's unacceptable and i will not
shut up about it yeah i'm with you i
feel the same way and by the way on the
mike lindell part of this not only was
he booted personally from twitter but
they also took
out the my pillow account so in essence
saying we're not even going to let you
sell pillows um pete as an atheist
in this time you know that i i've been
saying for quite some time it was a
weird realization for me
but that the the purely secular
worldview
works at the micro level but it seems
like it's not working at the macro
level anymore that that woke-ism is sort
of the end of the purely secular
view what's your take on that at this
point well
certainly it's an achilles heel i'm kind
of still caught up in what
eric just said i just find that i just
find that astonishing
um i'll answer your question directly
but
i don't know if i would jump to assume
that that
google is out to get me necessarily i
mean i
did you press them did you call them and
ask for no no
this has never happened before it
happened to all the eric mataxis
accounts now there's my whole staff
their emails shut down and we
posted this you know today and i knew it
was
hot stuff but i thought in america
that they would do this doesn't it tell
you and there was no
when you asked them there was no
response they didn't tell you why your
emails were shut down
my my no they absolutely did not and my
staff is looking into it right now
uh but i am it's just mind-blowing to me
there's nobody to call it you at google
there's no google
phone number there's no there's no
customer service i mean that's the irony
about
how big they've become but but go ahead
well okay well we can we can i'd like to
linger on that but that's okay so i
think that the
so it's very interesting to me having
this conversation and being on
with folks and i'm familiar with
everyone's work here the rabbi's work
and eric's work
and what's interesting to me is what's
so important
now wasn't important before and this is
interesting how the culture has shifted
and the times have shifted so
now metaphysics is really unimportant
whether there was a talking snake
whether someone walked on water it just
seems like
those seems like such quaint questions
and having debates about these things
seems so
rather silly i think what's important
now is that we all share a mutual threat
and that is we're in the middle of a
cultural revolution
and we see that the society is under
siege by maniacs who've
taken control of our institutions and it
could very well be that eric's story is
a simple example that where people try
to take away our liberties i can't speak
to that but
i think that you're right dave that
woke-ism it's a it's a universal solvent
it is the achilles heel of not just
liberalism but it destroys absolutely
everything it touches even
the southern baptists and so what i
think is really important in this
conversation
are some of the things that three people
of different backgrounds can agree upon
and i'll throw this out possibly as a
conversation starter
we all agree on the rules of engagement
so
those rules of engagement are
conversation like we're having now i
guess debate if you have to
but they're dialectical their speech so
we agree on that
i'm not going to call david uh
i was going to say some something that i
promised
exactly
so i'm not gonna i'm not gonna smear
people we're gonna converse in good
faith we're gonna have that conversation
and we're gonna be will it certainly i
would sincerely say i'd be willing to
change my mind and my guess is
that your guests would too are presented
with sufficient evidence
so so we agree upon that the other thing
is we agree upon
a correspondence theory of reality so we
think that we can come to truth
not based upon our subjective
experiences of
or appear this way we all believe that
we can come to truth
not based upon one's immutable
characteristics the color of our skin
or whatever that doesn't limit us from
finding the truth and those two rules
and
the rules of engagement and the idea
that your immutable characteristics
don't
uh particularly race or sexual
orientation or gender
don't prevent you from finding the truth
means that the three of us have
more in common right now than what's
what we see as the reigning moral
orthodoxy
can i add i mean i certainly agree with
that
um but i'd like to add another
characteristic and bring in the other
side
here which is that the degree
of your indignance or your anger is no
indicator of the degree of the
correctness of your views
and this is a malady and this is a
malady left and right
i see it from both sides and i get it as
as i'm sure
you sometimes do on my twitter and on my
facebook from both sides
people who are incapable of containing
their rage
and they're convinced that their rage
proves
how just as they are and how right they
are
and that is a is a poison it is
it's a it's a sort of ecumenical toxic
poison that moves through
that he's moving through our system um
and is making it really difficult to
talk across
the political divide and the last thing
that i would also say is my guess is
although i don't know everybody on this
call well enough to say this but i'm
going to make the guess
nonetheless unfortunately for much of
america since there is no shared culture
anymore
everything is politics you can't be sure
that someone else
has read the same books or listened to
the same music or whatever
the one thing you can be sure of is that
you share the possibility of talking
about politics
and and the recognition that there is
much much more to life
than politics alone is a recognition
that would help america a lot because
now everything is politicized
and it's not good yeah so actually rabbi
i want to stay with you for a moment on
that because
the fact that everything has become so
politicized i think is directly
correlated to why
seemingly so many people are so
miserable what what are you
able to do as the leader of a community
to inoculate
your your your people from that well i i
would love to be able to say that my
people are inoculated um
but but what i tried to do is to put out
consistently messages as as
you just saw me do this last moment that
are not political
because rather than feeding into the
insatiable maw of the political machines
right and left what i try to remind
people is that
you know um that part of life um
uh that there's so
there's so much to life that that
politics does not intrude on if you
don't want it to
and most of it by the way has to do with
how you conduct yourself your
relationship to other human beings
your relationship to god your
relationship to your own soul
those are not essentially political
categories and that is
most of our life um how
how small the part that men endure kings
or laws can cause or cure as i think was
tennyson wrote
and and that is still true except that
we don't live that way eric do you think
that that sort of what's going on here
that we're all now sort of trying to
find meaning through politics because
that's the only thing
that brings us all together as you know
we used to have
you know you could turn on the 6 30 news
and we could all sort of agree that that
was the reality but we just don't have
that anymore
i'm still stuck on uh the fact that the
rabbi used the phrase insatiable maw
because i think that's a porn film
about uh some hillbillies
but let me just say this please please
not everything
try to be serious um i think
uh what what the rabbi said is true
except i would say
it's really not on both sides i would
say that fundamental i mean look
people on both sides get angry and
scream and there are maniacs on both
sides but
the fundamental principle at the heart
of emotionalism
whatever it is is a utopianist
strain that you see in revolutions going
back to the french
revolution it is an attempt to reduce
everything to political categories and
it believes
that reducing things to political
categories and it believes in
reductionism in reducing
people you're in or you're out you're
good or you're bad you're woke or you're
evil
that kind of reductionism is a radical
left
world view and it touches everything
people on the other side of the
political spectrum
i think have a very different view
and i think conservative values would
lead you
to believe in in poetry and in art and
in all those
kinds of things and the nuances of
culture and the little platoons and
family and church and and i don't think
people on the left see it that way they
are about a revolution
they're about power and reducing things
reductionism in general
demonizing opponents you know as a
christian for example i
i'm supposed to pray for my enemies i'm
supposed to love my enemies it doesn't
mean i won't fight them
but i don't demonize them i don't
dehumanize them
because they're created in the image of
god people on the left
i don't think they have that problem i
think that they
are very happy to reduce people to
you're my enemy and i want to crush you
i don't care how i crush you there are
no rules
so i don't think it's really a
bipartisan problem
pete what do you think about that
because you're a sort of lifelong lefty
and
an atheist and a secularist but i think
at least partially
you agree with that because who's always
trying to cancel you it's it's not
the christian conservatives or the
orthodox church
so no certainly sure certainly not
part of the problem is that this
we have to look at this big picture
stuff and
historically i think is also important
this is an invasive value
this neo-racism that we're seeing now is
an invasive value
critical social justice under whatever
name if you want to
if there's a suite of ideologies that
takes place in my first book i talked
about how this is more or less
parasitized the liberal mind
so there are achilles heels in
liberalism and that's the other thing
about this that
underneath all of this there's a kernel
of truth
yes there has been historical racism yes
there has been historical and there
still is
racism and sexism whether or not that's
institutionalized we can we can talk
about that but
i think it's really important to
differentiate
when we're talking about liberalism
leftism being on the left being on the
right
first i think that those categories
don't have as much significance now
they're certainly not demarcated as
clearly as they used to be
you know 2015 certainly when i was
growing up
excuse me but i think that the way to
look at this
is and then i would add one one more
thing to what eric said
is that this really is a parasitization
of
the values that people hold and the
other thing is i think that
undergirding all of this is the idea
that
holding a belief you know that's a key
component of ideologues they believe
that holding a belief makes them a
better person
dan denna calls that belief and belief
so
so that's you see that both on the left
and on the right and i i want to echo
what the rabbi said
you know it's this toxin
is so dangerous and it's so contagious
that it's destroyed friendship
i have friends in my who have been in my
home good friends of my
guy who came out when my dad died
actually i saw you right after that
dave who no longer speak to me literally
and it's about a political disagreement
friends i've had my whole life don't
speak to me about a political
disagreement
and i've approached them repeatedly and
yes i will
uh be forthcoming and say they were on
the left but i in no way do i think that
this
this problem is unique to the left
but i will say that it is the guiding or
underlying
drive of the neo-racist ideology that we
see
everywhere in society so removing like
some of the purely political side of it
rabbi have you seen
in the last year is there any other time
in your career that you saw more
sort of tumult within families because
of politics not even i know i'm going
through it in my own family right now
right
not even close and while i don't want to
enter the the the
the um left-right ideological
distinctions because i think there
are distinctions um and and they are
important and i don't want to i don't
want to deny that but
but my my principal concern especially
as a rabbi to people
um and knowing that arguing people out
of their political ideology
is is a rarely successful
task um my my read
of the level of anger is
that it is equal at least on both sides
or and as virulent and i actually also
have lost friends
um both right and left um
from this from this same one very close
um who i would be objected to one thing
that i said and that was it
um and won't talk about it uh he's from
the right but um
but it's can i ask what that is uh
yes um we had talked about we talked
about i said um
something very similar to what peter
said which is that racism does exist
in this society and and as soon as he
heard that it was
blm burning cities you're okay with that
and i said
no obviously not i've spoken against it
and i
certainly um am i'm anti-woke
in in very serious ways um
but but i try so hard
to give everybody a fair hearing and so
i'm really i'm constantly
when you do that what happens is on the
other side the fair hearing is heard as
you're a partisan of the other side
and correct that's a function that's a
function of
an emotional reaction now i'm not
talking about historically ideological
emotionalism
that's a that's really a much more
theoretical question
at the moment to me than the emotional
reaction of the individual right or left
to hearing someone that they think of as
an ally because they've heard them say
things in the past that they agree with
say something now that indicates they're
part of the other side because
the last point i want to make is what
i've discovered
is what makes the current situation so
toxic
is when you say something that is not in
conformity
with your ideology as you previously
expressed it
it isn't that you are starting an
argument it's that you're losing
your compatriots and friends there are
two teams
and you can't break from your team we've
seen this politically
look anybody who broke from the team
was tossed out and that's
a very bad way to to conduct oneself
in life because it makes critical
engagement impossible
you can say anything critical you want
to the other side
and i'm hearing a lot of that even on
this call but you can't say anything
critical about your own team
because you'll be a betrayer um that's
not good
and by the way this isn't something that
you're just saying you've lived this
because you were one of the first
the first rabbis maybe the first in los
angeles to allow for gay marriage at
your synagogue and i know that caused
all sorts of problems from from more
right huge
yes it was a huge outcry um and it was
on the front page of the ellie and the
new york times that's how big now cry it
was but
but i will tell you um i've told the
story before but i have
i have a a daughter who uh is now in her
early 20s but at the time was a young
teenager
and and saw all this and was a little
bit alarmed
and i told her what churchill said uh
after combat he said is
exhilarating to be shot at without
result you know the knowledge that you
can come through a controversy
and the people who you counted on are
still there and you
you feel okay about yourself that's a
very growthful
experience so so eric i'm curious
if you see that there's some sort of
christian awakening happening because
i sense something happening within the
christian community and i know just from
the last couple years
as i've talked about all of these things
and had all sorts of different thinkers
and believers and non-believers on
that to me i went to liberty university
it's the largest evangelical christian
college in the united states i spoke at
their sunday invocation
in front of 14 000 people i mean it was
it was it felt like a political rally it
was crazy
they know my they know i'm married to a
man they know some of my other beliefs
that are not thought of as traditionally
christian beliefs
i was welcomed in that campus in in an
absolutely extraordinary way and i sense
something good
sort of happening in the christian
community right now do you sense that
i do but once again i have to go back to
a word that the rabbi used
he said growth full
speaking as a writer somebody who cares
about words i just want to say
that's the ugliest word i have heard in
weeks
growth full is not a word please don't
ever use that again
that's the deal breaker for me punk no
so look
there is no question that uh something
is happening
uh in the church in among christians
there's a lot of division too
um but i see people
i mean especially those of us um
who were upset by the election
there's a lot of prayer and as somebody
who
you know literally believes in god not
as an idea
but stuff happens
when people pray um and and i am
absolutely convinced that
uh we are going to
find ourselves in some ways as a result
of the madness
that is happening right now and these
expressions
really of vileness just anti-american
uh fascist censorship and that kind of
thing i think it's driving people back
to the roots
and by roots uh among other things i
mean a very
a serious kind of faith that says what
really matters
at this point uh if if the government is
is shutting down my email and they i
can't
you know you you you suddenly say wait a
minute
what is really what is really important
and what are the values
that are the basis for what i believe in
so i think that we're being forced to
think about
what is freedom how do you get a free
society and i would argue
and have argued and written about it
that you cannot have american style
self-government without virtue
and you're not going to have much virtue
without expressions of faith and that
these things are important
but we haven't been able we we haven't
been forced to think about
this because we've been living in a
relatively free society for decades and
decades and we just haven't ever been
pushed to think
well could we lose that so suddenly when
you begin losing it you think
what is it that sustains that and why
did we take our eye off the ball we need
to get back to that
yeah absolutely um i want to respond to
first of all
uh with all due respect to eric's
aesthetic sense of the language
growthful is in fact a
excuse me word me eric it is out of the
dictionary it is a word and it's a far
less disgusting word
than punk the f word is in the
dictionary
all right that's right i think back punk
i take back punk okay
all right i'm gonna need the atheist to
clean this up i'm going to need the
atheist
and i'm going to come in and clean this
up let me let me ask you this
which is that for if if there is some
sort of
renewal happening within the christian
community the atheist community sort of
had that
like about six or eight years ago there
was this new atheist movement
i spoke at the reason rally i mean there
was a feeling of like this purely
secular worldview that could really work
it seems to have completely collapsed at
this point
what do you make of the atheist movement
if there is such a thing
at this point i think the atheist
mythius movement well the new atheist
movement is certainly dead it was
destroyed by the thing that's destroying
us all now it was the precursors the
canary in the coal mine which was
wokism uh i want back to something that
david said
uh it it's really resonating with me can
i ask you
how old was your friend that your former
friend
he was he's probably said that to you
mid to mid to late 70s
oh wow so that's not the answer i was
expecting
um i think one of the one of the
problems
i think we have two problems one is that
there's a whole infrastructure that's
currently in place
and there's a language that's why i'm
surprised with 70.
they'll call it co-platforming or even
speaking to someone makes you an enemy
or even oh no he was on the right
he was on the right not on the left no i
know but that that
that same kind of parallelism in the
architecture of how we defend our
beliefs and how
to correct me if i'm wrong but if
if you would be willing to have a
conversation with him again
and talk about your friendship correct
i've tried
sure yeah and and that's one of the
things that's so disturbing to me
is that he probably does not as i've
approached my friends who have not
right and so part of the part of the
problem is that a few things one
we have to value the right things and
and i
while i certainly have again
metaphysical disagreements with the
other people on this call
what i value what we all value is
cognitive liberty
i value the rabbi's to believe i value
eric's right to believe i value
they have every right to worship and
every right to pray as they want and
that's
and i have every right to to disagree
with the
contents of those beliefs and if i if i
want i'm not so inclined but challenge
them to a debate or have a conversation
about it
but what we see now is a kind of tyranny
we see a kind of tyranny about among
people
who certain they don't want certain
beliefs to enter the public square and
i'm not talking about they've expanded
the umbrella of racism to such a crazy
degree that everything is now racist
conversation is racist public speech
acronyms are racist
knitting is race dungeons and dragons is
now anti-semitic
particularly pain to me so the question
is how do we help
people value the right things value the
cognitive liberty of others
value civilized conversation value
getting beyond politics i mean it's the
polarization is so
intense right now i have never in my 54
years of life seen anything like it
and i think at some point in this call
we have to talk about
solutions to these maladies or else
we're just people complaining about
well you know my philosophy on that it's
like let's let's actually figure out
what we can
do so that that is where we'll end but
i'm curious rabbi going off what pete
just said there
um are people how much of the sort of
struggle that you're sensing from people
is because they literally cannot get
together in los angeles even now
yeah i'm the pandemic certainly
exacerbates
all of this there's no question about it
um and
also as does the and
and part of this is um there
is a a a status to grievance
that makes it really difficult um
to give someone their due because you
know
robert frost said that poetry is made of
griefs not grievances
but we've become a society that even
though we have real griefs
grievances predominate things that are
not correct
griefs but our grievances and and as
long as they are acknowledged as giving
someone
the status that they're that they
currently do
it's going to be hard to dig our way out
of this um
the other the one thing about the
pandemic of course that
will i hope get better once the vaccines
are widely spread and so on
is to actually see another face
to see another human being to encounter
them
to to to realize and recognize their
humanness and as eric said the
recognition that they're in the image of
god
that is elevating and healing and i
really do hope
that uh that what can't happen over
social media can happen over uh you know
restaurant tables
um that people will start to see one
another for their fundamental
uh humanness and and not
uh as as political entities or racial
entities
or or um or people of different
ethnicities as opposed to just
people yeah and it's just incredible to
me how quickly we forget all of this you
know from living in la for the last year
where in essence we haven't been
you know been able to go out i know i
have people at my house in in what i
think are highly illegal gatherings but
uh i was in texas last week and i went
to a restaurant with some friends and
even to just interact with the waiter
was just like okay that's the stuff we
used to do it used to be pretty boring
and now it's like oh i'm talking to
another human being how
how exciting let's get to the solutions
part though let's spend the last 10
minutes talking about that
uh eric what do you think
we can do to fix some of this stuff to
to get back to something that feels more
okay look i think you have to be honest
about some things here the grievance
culture the idea that if i have a
grievance
it elevates me that uh
is a culturally marxist worldview
it's about us versus them it's about
power it's not about truth goodness and
beauty it's about
power and if somebody can get power
cultural power from uh being part of a
of a grievance uh you know uh
category of course they're gonna use
that i remember
when i was at yale before i had any kind
of faith buying into that idea that you
know
that those people in power their scum
their they they
i felt completely free to despise them
i can only speak uh from my point of
view but the bible says
to me it commands me to look at my
enemies as made in the image of god even
if i have to kill them in a fight i
don't do it very joyfully i do it
with with grief that is a world view
that i don't think
unless you're willing to tell people
with this culturally marxist
woke world view that is hurtful that has
never worked that has led to blood baths
in the past you need to understand that
you need to understand that
this will never lead to a culture where
people get
blessed i i think we we have to call it
out and also i will say this
it's one thing for some 21 year old
maniac to behaving a certain way and to
be get culture get get cultural status
from that kind of thing but when
corporations
worth billions of dollars support this
kind of thinking when they support the
cancel culture we don't need to talk
about the idiots at big tech
okay but when i'm talking about
corporations uh
we had bed bath and beyond kohl's
heb stores wayfarer stores all canceled
mike
lindell because they didn't like what
you know they they
but the real issue and this goes back to
you know what uh
al sharpton would do and and and jesse
jackson would do
they would shake people down they would
say to corporations unless you do this
we're going to put you on the front page
you're a racist corporation
so they're all running in fear and if
you do not have
courage and most of these folks have no
courage they will throw you under the
bus
they will do business with china they
would do business with nazi germany
they have no values it's about money
it's about staying out of trouble
unless you have moral values and unless
you have
courage uh we are going to get
more of the same these corporations have
tremendous power and i'm just telling
you right now
they would happily do business with
nazis they do not
care if uighur muslims are being
murdered
and tortured they don't care if they can
make money and stay
out of the way of the woke mob if the
woke mob doesn't come for them
i wrote a book about nazi germany i
wrote a book about dietrich bonhoeffer
that's what happened in germany the
germans were not evil people they were
just like the americans today they
didn't want trouble
and they were willing cravenly to do
what was necessary to look the other way
when bad things were happening
that's all it takes that is what's
happening in america today and if we
don't have some courage
that is the path we're on there's no
other way ideologically
that's where we're going well said look
pete i you know it's interesting because
eric's talking about how this has
infected the corporations you've been
you've been fighting this thing forever
i actually remember
that one of the real moments that i woke
up to all of this was when you invited
me to speak at portland state university
and it was me you and christina hop
summers and antifa
showed up and they said that you were a
white supremacist and i was a homophobe
and christina
hated women and and police had to escort
us
and also andy know who was just you know
a young kid at the time who now
is is like one of the prime fighters of
this he was there
but you've been doing it on the campus
thing and everyone kept saying us hey
it's staying on the campuses you guys
are nuts
and to eric's point it's everywhere now
so what
can we do to what can we actually do and
not just talk about it
okay so i'll speak to what we speak to
what we can do about it on the campuses
and then i'll speak to what we can do
about it in our own lives
one word that's come up over and over
again is grievance
and we've we've gone our universities
and institutions have gone from engines
of knowledge production to engines of
grievance indoctrination
and that's what we're seeing now the
perennial and perpetual
feeding into peoples you have to find
this grievant any disparity is
because of something systemically racist
i mean there is a whole
system in place to indoctrinate young
people
so that that is a a problem i've talked
about the ways to get out of that you
basically have a ways to
get get around ideology or place
how do you place truth front and center
to that i will be very blunt with you i
used to be pollyanna about the
universities thinking they would change
i no longer believe that's possible i
think we need new institutions
and the pandemic has expedited that and
we may
very soon we've already seen the
collapse of smaller universities tier
one universities will be fine
so so part of that is
that we we've created a mono culture in
which people don't hear the other side
i mentioned before the call started that
when i teach my atheism class i often
have people come into the class who
don't share my world view
because of what mill said about it's not
good enough that they hear it they have
to hear it from people
who believe it in my pseudo-science and
pseudoscience class i have people come
in
who talk about ufo abductions or
mark sargent who's one of the leaders in
the flat earth will give the best
arguments that he can for why
why he believes the earth is flat those
arguments now are different from
anything dealing with certain
morally taboo issues like protected
classes
which is an entirely different story
because
we're not allowed for example i have
been
more or less read the riot act about
in in the university and i teach ethics
and i teach critical thinking
about rendering my views about uh
protected classes etc
so the universities are in crisis right
now the second thing is
when you were taught your whole life and
to find grievances particularly kids
my uh daughters i'm wondering if this is
a mistake could i say this
but my daughter's math assignment was to
draw
math assignment was my daughter's health
assignment
was to in health class was to draw a
picture of a black person
my daughter's assignment in math class
was to find
uh african-am watch african-american
films on tv about how
african americans have been wiped out of
history
now i think the latter is extremely
important
but not in math class so that
even the traditional structures of this
is what you teach in math this is what
you see
all of those things have been undermined
but okay so back to the point what do we
do about it
there's so much grievance everywhere and
we're we're teaching people in schools
to find grievance here's something that
i do
uh as you know i'm an atheist i don't
think there's sufficient evidence to
justify belief in god or miracles or any
divine intervention
and so i don't pray but what we do is we
have a family dinner every night
and we go around the table and we say
what we are grateful for
every person says what they're grateful
for
and it's amazing how just showing a
little gratitude
for something in your life washes away
so much of that grievance
so so we have to start adopting
practices
not not only broad more broadly to
repudiate grievance ideology
but in our own lives to forefront other
things
like you know truth
if you if you know the rabbi and eric
would say faith that's not my thing but
find something to push the
idea that there are constant perpetual
grievances popping up everywhere
and replace that with something more
productive to help people live more
meaningful lives
so rabbi i'll i'll give you we're here
as as
pete's talking about you know having a
meal with his family and and having
gratitude and all of that well it'll be
sundown in a couple hours i know you'll
be doing shabbat i'll be doing it as
well which is not something i was really
doing a year or two ago
but i've found meaning in it now um is
that is that really the answer
uh well i i don't know that shabbat is
the answer
certainly shabbat is part of an answer
the appreciation of the universe the
connection to something greater than
oneself
all of that the other two things that i
would mention
are in these discussions i think it's
incredibly productive
if you can do it to start with what your
side is doing wrong
because the lobbing of bombs over the
wall doesn't it doesn't advance the
discussion
your team will cheer you on and that
will feel great
and the other side won't hear what
you're saying so i think that part of
listening
is being willing to be self-critical and
i don't think there's nearly
enough of that that's one thing that i
would say and then the second
is you have to find people of different
views on whom you can cooperate
on things that are not centrally
political you know putting up a stop
sign on your
corner you know going together with your
kids to get
uh to for school or when the time comes
um but essentially as i said it
is to understand that the
that the deep humanness of human beings
is shared all across cultures all across
time all across history
that ev that's why we read the bible
everything has changed since the time of
the bible technology
language everything except human nature
and so we are still in all of this
together and we still struggle together
and we still face doubts and fears and
pandemics the entire world faced it
so some of the divisions that seem so
important today will crumble
in the face of things that are bigger
and more important
and uh and i wish there were there was
less the tone of a sacred
crusade whether from right or from left
and
and more the tone of we will find our
way through this together
if we can just listen and
let the walls come down a little bit
and let the heart open a little more
well
i will take that as the final word as i
roll into a weekend that i
will not be on twitter that's that's one
other way that we can add a little
something to this uh gentlemen thanks a
lot i realize now because the rabbi and
i are here in los angeles and eric
you're in new york pete you're in
portland when we do this in person and i
i would love to do it in person perhaps
sheboygan wisconsin would that
with that spot that's the spot
gentlemen thank you so much and uh i i
hope to see you guys in real life
thank you in the not too distant future
thanks have a great day for the weekend
yes don't watch this it's a terrible
film
one hoax all right take care guys
i really have nothing to add i i hope
that that had some value to you
it had some value to me and uh as i said
i'm gonna try to be off the twitter
on the weekend and i do try to make my
weekends not political and i hope that
uh i hope that some of the stuff there
from a christian perspective from a
jewish perspective from a purely secular
atheist perspective
i hope you can see that we all have a
lot more in common and i know that most
of you that
view this show you know that right and
even when i'm
railing on what's going on with the with
the lefties or or the crazy thing that
aoc
said this day or how terrible cnn is or
whatever it might be it's like
the rabbi's right like we are all in
this together whether we like it or not
and the great challenge of america going
forward is
in a country that was designed as as
something that was for everybody for us
all to come here
and and be better together actually
together the melting pot do it together
bring all your traditions bring all your
foods all of
the stuff that made your family whatever
it was can we all bring it here
and and build something that's better
than that and we did a pretty good job
of it for a long time it feels like it's
a little tenuous right now
and we just got to get back to it so
that's what i'm going to try to do have
a great weekend everybody
uh and oh well i'll post some pictures
on reubenreport.locals.com
that'll be some some food and some dogs
over there but no politics
all right thanks everybody